libertarians
over 95 percent of voters either don't
know who libertarians are or they see us
as even if they agree with us even the
majority of libertarians self-identified
libertarians who do not vote libertarian
the reason they don't is because they
see us as a joke they see that we they
believe that we can't get elected and
they think well why would i bother doing
that i'm going to try to figure out
which side this time is marginally
better than you you say that stat one
more time 95 percent what well i mean
look at the numbers like the highest
we've ever gotten is what was three
point something percent with with gary
and bill and that was in a time with
uniquely uh with with terrible
candidates with uh trump and hillary
like unpopular candidates uh trump
didn't have the following he did in 2016
that he did in 2020 he's the most
popular libertarian out there the most
popular i'm holding it now in new york
state about six percent no but in the
country
the most popular for his ninety-five
percent
nationally yeah
nationally who's the most popular
libertarian clint eastwood is not vocal
okay uh you got uh
185 years old vince vaughn is not vocal
okay
you got rand paul that's very vocal but
you know again uh republican he didn't
run as a libertarian
yeah yeah you know you got ron paul who
is dog the guy that knows how to sell it
better than anybody else that he's but
he's aging he's not you know so you
there's a there's a few of them i mean
joe rogan could be
conce he voted for george oregon he's
going to support the libertarian party
um but you know those are the names they
don't have like you need a face
please i'm the guy running let me tell
you this right now let me be very clear
we do have faces it's just hard we got
guys like shane hazel running for
governor in in georgia we got uh we we
we got uh mark tibbetts running in texas
i've if i've never heard of the names
you're saying yeah then you don't have a
face we have ricky if i have to go
google ricky harrington yes because i've
never heard him by the way google ricky
yes you're missing the point here i'm
not i'm here trying to get this out you
need nobody like you need a tom hanks
you need a rock you need that okay but
it's so clear even though tom hanks or a
rock we still have to show people how
our ideas work that's not the debate
though but clearly you guys know what
you're talking about please clearly you
have a great
let me deal with this for one second i'm
telling you why they're not coming to us
because we don't have the infrastructure
to support them it isn't our ideas we
require infrastructure why would you run
libertarian when you'd have to fight to
get enough people on the ballot you'd
have to fight to get on the ballot
period you'd have to fight to get
signatures fight to come up with a bunch
of people who could support you fight to
find the funding base you you don't run
libertarian because you don't care about
libertarians you don't want to return
because you can get a you can get it but
i don't know i don't even think you're
if the rock ran as a libertarian they'd
have a hard time
more votes yes would they win absolutely
not and another big part of that is but
that's the
step it is step by step but there's
another step-by-step process which is
doing that the majority yeah i don't
know if you're popular enough i like you
i think you're charismatic the majority
you're not the rock brother guys let me
let me hear what spike is saying hang on
hang on one second
if you were correct yeah then michael
bloomberg would be our independent
president
he's not
be why the system is is set up to not
work i don't think i'm gonna save the
world but do i think i could be the guy
who sets it up for the world to be saved
yes i do because i am building out the
infrastructure as you said step by step
like we're not doing it i'm literally
here doing it it is being done so that
in 2024 in 2028 when kurt russell
decides to come aboard or drew carey
both libertarians one of those two guys
come aboard we have an infrastructure
set they're happy to do it or whomever
is the rock comes over we don't have
enough to give them now but we have to
build up and we are and it takes local
people building up local groups local
infrastructure
donor bases our uh pr bases all those
things to make that happen
can i i'm sorry go ahead well and
the vast majority of voters long before
they want to they trust a libertarian to
handle the wars or china or immigration
they want to see how they handle their
pothole in their in their neighborhood
like libertarians have won hundreds of
local races hundreds out of literally
tens of thousands we've won zero
statewide races we've done zero federal
races we won
zero of them yes there's ballot access
problems and everything else but there's
an even bigger problem which is that
most voters even if they hear our ideas
they go yeah that sounds great in theory
but how's it going to work in practice
we need to focus local we need to build
an actual infrastructure for the party
to work our way up because if we get a
dwayne the rock johnson he might will he
get double digits as a libertarian yes
is he going to win it absolutely not
because people at the end of the day
they're going to go yeah dwayne johnson
great rock great but this party i know
nothing about them they've never won
before what would they actually do if
they did one uh you know i'm worried
about
the the kitchen table issues like
healthcare and education and housing and
the cost of living and everything else
and just the fact that a very popular
guy is running or or woman is running
for office is not going to be enough for
them to say okay i'm going to break free
from the system that's been running this
country for over 100 years now we have
to build the infrastructure so i think
we need them and that will also bring a
big game why would the rock come let me
read a super chat here from hector ross
larry knows what he's talking about
howard stern openly contemplated running
libertarian as new york governor but
backed out for lack of infrastructure at
the time i have some feedback there but
i want to hear david and i want to kind
of give you what i'm what i'm thinking
go ahead okay so i i tend to agree i
think we're almost talking about
different things here i mean look if
somebody like the rock was truly
converted to libertarianism and like i
believe this now and i want to be like
the champion for it that would be
amazing i mean that would be incredible
what it could do for us and so i agree
with you on that but the thing is this
right you've basically had over the last
uh let's say
10 15 years right you've had
essentially third party candidates who
ran within the two major parties so ron
paul was a third-party candidate in
spirit he didn't believe what the what
the republican establishment did bernie
sanders was essentially a third party
candidate and donald trump essentially
won as a third-party candidate however
the way the system is set up in order
for them to do that it's not to their
advantage to go to some third party to
their advantage to stay in one of the
major two parties what we're sitting
here saying is that the problem is that
that never actually works for what our
desired outcomes are which is really
rolling back the state now donald trump
i agree with spike kind of yeah if he
had run third party that would have made
it a lot harder for him to do what he
needs to do i'd love for that famous
person who can move
people by the tens of millions to come
over to libertarianism but in the
meantime what are we supposed to do what
are we supposed to do are we supposed to
accept that these two parties who have
in effect committed treason against the
american people and we know nothing's
going to be solved from within them that
what we're just supposed to fall in line
because this one is five percent better
than the other one like that's not good
enough for me i don't think anybody
saying that well my point is that this
is the united states of america we
deserve something better than that and
so we're gonna keep fighting to try to
get this message out to as many people
as possible to hopefully put us in a
situation where we can get somebody like
that so or whatever is necessary to move
the needle look i agree with you if tom
hanks or the rock or some crazy famous
charismatic person wanted to take up the
mantle for this i'd be thrilled but
since we don't have that right now i the
best i can do is try to get on as many
huge platforms as i can speak to as many
people as i can build up our army you
know metaphorically speaking not a real
state army um and and try to you know
monetize
well it sounds like you guys need to be
able to walk and chew gum at the same
time yeah because i didn't know that
about the libertarian infrastructure
like i'm learning that we're all
learning that but it sounds like you
guys need to build out the
infrastructure but also get someone that
gets eyeballs because joe jorgensen's
not the answer we all know that let me
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]
you